we're talking to break about our kids
and I was telling you how much my
children my daughter's 13 my son is is
11 and how much they just loved this
film you have kids that are a little
younger than mine yeah yeah - yeah my
son is eight my daughter seeks did you
ever bring them to the set because I
mean I was a god just for taking them to
the movie you can take them to the
actual world it's like I mean you know
my work has always separated me you know
so it was always a negative thing for my
kids you know it's that thing that keeps
daddy away and this time I was it was
the opposite it was like you gotta get
to work
you know you know these are words that I
could say going yeah I take my son to
set and that was amazing you know we
were in the in the rebel station we were
in the oven and and my son is seeing the
x-wings and all the rebels and he gets
to play with the weapons and everything
fantastic day the best day you know in
his life and then the producer comes and
says hey kiddo anymore we're so glad to
have you here and we just want to remind
you that you cannot talk about what
happened here in a year okay I got the
whole year and he's how old he's eight
that's a lot to tell an eight-year-old
yeah yeah he goes yeah of course of
course
and I'm seeing him like oh god this is
gonna get me to trouble like five months
later we were in a holiday in the beach
and we were in the pool and I see him
talking to four girls sixteen year olds
and I got like first he's like well done
I mean he's getting that definitely yeah
he's like doing the right thing so I
just want to hear what he's saying just
to see what cars he's pulling out of his
leave and yeah I swim and I and I get
close and I start listening well not you
have to understand this is a film with
no Jedi sits about gravel
okay can I get it's gonna get cheese -
yeah yeah gonna get you arrested
you